a lot of people don't know what it's
like to be in a real relationship I just
kept really relationships they consist
of times like this the whole quarantine
thing and nothing new to a person isn't
a real relationship to somebody whether
it's a road trip for 38 hours weathers
getting stuck at the airport whether
it's an overnight hospital visit because
the chair in sick what if your partner
is sick whether it's going to go visit
that person's family they stay on the
middle Alabama do 450 miles I agree
before you move in with someone
okay this is marriage tip number two go
on a trip and you're gonna know usually
see things that are getting on your
nerves like oh they don't pick
themselves up and they always you go to
know right away and if the person gets
on your nerves and all-inclusive and
they get on your nerves then don't move
with them because if they get on your
nerves if you ain't got your clothes to
wash you ain't got to do no groceries
you ain't got to do the dishes you ain't
got to take out the trash if all all the
chores are taken away and that person
still gets on your nerves
do not move with them because the one
real big thing comes in and you got to
take out the trash make some food go get
the groceries go get the kids this and
that and that person is not
participating mmm that person yeah you
don't move with that person ever there
are times where you have to be somebody
man and I'm looking a lot of people who
are struggling to be right there in the
same space um of course you don't want
to be up under the same person like 24
hours a day but you should be straight
up miserable if you aren't in a
relationship with somebody you chose
because the chemistry and compatibility
will create your ability to be around
them and y'all not be at each other's
necks you know I'm just sayin I feel
like complete strangers get to know them
talk to them not everything in a
relationship is gonna be
relationshipgoals or you posted up you
know valet in front of the BMW i8 or
some [ __ ] like that for Instagram
sometimes y'all gonna be up in the house
and y'all gonna be wearing some basic
ass stuff all damn day
you know the hair gonna be done to do a
it's gonna be on the body's gonna be on
and y'all really gotta just talk and be
with each other that's a real
relationship so I need to say this ma'am
and
think this needs to be like a new rule
if y'all can't quarantine together you
know probably don't need to be together
I got agree except this devotion a
little bit I gotta agree with it I'm
just interesting the idea of like you
guys can't quarantine together you
probably shouldn't be together it's
interesting that is to me but it's not
the definition of everybody like there's
some people that really hurt I'm gonna
do an impression of a girl I heard of
the bar talking to her man okay yo
seriously like you don't you don't show
me love you don't show me that you love
me like you're for real like you don't I
mean sometimes you know she pissed it
out of me you know all like slap Academy
Academy like you don't do nothing it's
like do you want to eat this yeah okay
and in that fit just like slap of God I
mean you know just say no you know say
something like you're always so you're
always so nice just sometimes you know
just you know she knows I'm not in the
mood you don't do something you never do
show me something you know show me that
you're alive
I want to feel you I see me in my head I
was like bro run I mean that's a very
like toxic form a very toxic example if
there's some people there's level three
of course I feel like it's interesting
that not being able to be around someone
for long extended periods of time we're
talking weeks and months here it's
somehow an indication that your
relationship is no good I'm just like I
just find it interesting that the
difference between tolerance and
compromise and how we define the two
differently it just doesn't seem that
clear to me but I'm just observing right
and we always say that relationships is
about compromise is that you sense
you're going to tolerate things that you
may not necessarily like because it's
for the betterment of the
I get that and so being in the personal
space of someone we're not talking about
like this is a weekend getaway a
quarantine is not just a three-day trip
it's like economically it's stressful
you may have lost your job financial
like your finances are really bad you
got to be uncertain about the future
paying bills so for me seeing couples
struggle through this time is not the
most abnormal thing because aside from
the individual struggles you have to be
around someone who you're not
necessarily used to being around 24/7
for multiple weeks inside your home it's
not like you're on a vacation
well you guys are breathing the fresh
air and going to a great destination the
destination at the end of this
quarantine is hemp nation after this
quarantine normal life most likely
wasn't that amazing to begin with so I
don't think that because people are
heavily struggling through this time
right now that it's necessary indication
that relationships are trash or this and
that I just also think there's a lot of
stress on people right now and very
valid stress and there's much
uncertainty what do you get by the
effect that a lot of people are like
filing for divorce right now I'm at the
break when I saw that I was so confused
on like how you doing lawyers
appointments over Skype we did like
could I get your services over Skype I
want to get rid of this beside me what
you do have to like see the delivery
room you're in
okay okay I'm gonna put you on mute
right now you right
it's just I've paid for lawyer services
before it's so expensive and the idea of
getting shaft this is bad enough but to
get shafted in the end via Skype hey
technology that's brutal people are
finding for divorces yeah I think it's
time for us to amend all the wedding
vows that we've written up until now
this whole death do us part
let's pad till quarantine do us part
alright let's add till the girl next
door is wait harder than you do this
part I'm gonna be with you through thick
and thin and let the girl next door as
Ruby
[Laughter]
we need to change these vows this is
brutal I will never hear wedding vows
and take them seriously ever it's just
pathetic we're two weeks into the
quarantine we haven't even hit a month
nine people have already given up yeah
you know I'm with this little time you
have to spend your significant other to
be like Oh tested I have I've been
tested actually I found out this morning
Oprah that I tested positive so you know
I'm not surprised as soon as I heard
that Idris was potentially exposed I
mean I was on my way anyways and I
wanted to be with him I think that's an
instinct as a wife you just want to go
and take care and you know we didn't
change the way we enter a discussion
catch that I just L but he got diagnosed
with the corona virus I'd like that we
could go or something like that and his
lady his wife should I say she decided
she wanted to quarantine with him
instead of getting a whole nother house
or just staying away from him and now
she also has I lived in the comments and
I saw other people talking about how
crazy she is they think anything is fake
matter of fact because she seems so
upbeat and happy but it thinks he's
crazy for not quarantine and away from
them so let me say this that woman ain't
crazy no woman is committed that woman
is good that wife is committed to just
go both got the virus she got it from
him do they have kids no oh well it's
not even risky to kids so it doesn't
even matter it's not the point it's not
a question of if it's armful to the kids
that's not the problem
if my husband catches it and I'm the
wife and then I'm both of you who's
gonna take care of the kids
at least if I croak my kids got a mom
I'm not gonna we're not gonna both I I
wanna be with him no boo-boo be with
your kids how you do it
okay don't have kids that's her decision
you know it affects a lot of people but
it's a decision
don't think is the smartest decision but
devoted I think it's kind of stupid to
be honest with you even I don't have any
kids my girl I'll be like y'all stay
away from you stay away from me I'm good
I'm gonna stay in this room you stay in
that room and that's gonna be that and
you don't step in the room close the
door everything
Florentino hope you won't feed me you
leave the the food at the door and
that's it that's to me that but that
[ __ ] I won't call it devotion I
don't think it's a sign of commitment to
say that you're gonna take of her son
just because your partner has it I mean
it's fake devotion it's stupidity
there's some things that people do they
make it look like romance and passion
and it's just shade of stupidity with
you know boots live because I see some
things sometimes on the web and it's
just like just quotes or some people's
and corny where they should go
relationship gold is just like as dumb
that's it for today's video
[Music]
but this whole topic of quarantine II
and being in a real relationship has
made me see something that I didn't
notice before a lot of people a lot of
people can't relate to even just being
in the same space with the person they
chose to be in a relationship with this
law like it's making a lot of people
struggle in this exposing the fact that
a lot of people don't know what it's
like to be in a real relationship
because they're so used to toleration
ships I was with him until he said
toleration [ __ ] that was so foggy but I
know what he means though and he's not
wrong I gotta give it to them the quoted
it was a bit corny but I ain't mad
there's a lot of people that wasn't
totally there just tolerating each other
yes isn't that most relationships you
tolerate each other to a point this
works as long as I don't got to be with
you five hours a day then it's too much
that's most people I don't have it's
most people I don't know I don't have
the numbers I'm not gonna say it's most
people there's a lot of people
definitely a lot of people the reality
is most people don't spend that much
time with their significant other but I
don't spend a lot of I don't I don't
spend I haven't that your brother is me
it's been worth 250 weeks I'm always
there my girls happy about that I'm
never home I do that usually like but I
mean it's we we cool and I don't think
there's a lot of people out there you
just cannot stand to be alone they
haven't learned this process in their
life to be alone so they can't stand it
therefore they hook up with anybody and
they stay there in our relationship when
that sure that relationship is garbaggio
garbage mm-hmm trash should stand but
what makes her trash the fact that they
can't be together for long periods of
time isn't that called compromise no not
necessarily I feel like most couples
tolerate each other but like it's a bad
thing
rough most old couples I know spend a
little too no time with like those
cities other silently or they'll try
that's most cut possible yeah there's a
difference between I've said everything
I had to say to that lady because we've
been together 60 years you know I mean I
thought when you're not gonna have
you're not gonna says much and the first
time you met you're not gonna talk
you're not gonna
a difference you know I mean of course
it's gonna be automatic I mean if I
spend enough time with some of my all
means I'm gonna be able to complete
their sentences
sure so of course with my wife at some
point sometimes it's like we don't talk
cuz we ain't got to talk
it's the difference between I don't talk
because I don't have to and I don't want
to talk because I hate this there is a
difference look at him and you ain't
doing nothing I'm thinking of all the
old couples I've ever seen in all of
them
there's just remember we talked about
this where it's just like the man it's
just very quiet about everything does it
talk yeah and the woman takes up all the
space
yeah and I mean is just giving up yeah I
feel like that's isn't relationships I
don't I try to work it not to be like
that but that's most relationships I'm
mad at you I don't think it's quite what
I'm talking about because it's this
degree and level finish if you meet my
dad and my mom is there you won't get to
know my dad because my mom takes up all
the space we also women take up all the
oh they take up all the space
yeah you have to take my data side and
then start talking to them because you
won't know my dad at all you know I mean
let's say you I bring you to my house
right you won't be able to sit down and
talk with my dad because my mom is
always going to be like in she's not a
good listener
so she cuts all the time and stuff like
that so my dad just like no I think
that's why I got it from him people
could be armed like yes you got from him
yeah I think so I think so I see it I
really fear